Ils sont jeunes, ils partagent
plusieurs priorités.
ier soir.
Je reçois Catherine Fournier,
nouvellede Longueuil
et Stéphane Boyer, nouveau maire
de Laval.
jeune maire de l'histoire
de Laval. Vous faites partie de
ce vent de changement qu'on a
observé hier dans plusieurs
municipalités au Québec.Vous fax
de ce vent de changement qu'on a
observé dans plusieurs grandes
villes.
À Laval concrèsieur
Boyer vous allait changer quoi
et à quelle vitesse?
participé et épris des décisions
dans lesivre dans les
mains dans les mêmes
orientations que les dernières
années.
lui-même mais peut-être la façon
de faire la politique des
différentes.
J'ai aussi une personnalité
différente que Monsieur Demers
et j'ai besoin de Laval ouvert
sur le monde.
- Un exemple concret.
Qu'allez-vous faire de
différents que Monsieur Demers?
- Laval est souvent vu comme une
ville de banlieue mais je crois
que c'est de moins en moins
cas et je souhaite que la ville
soit ouverte sur le monde et
forger des partenariats et à
er.
Tenir des événements
internationaux sur le territoire
c'est important.
La moitié de la population et
s'il immigration et la place des
jeunes à Laval vont vers
Montréalétudes et je
souhaite Laval et Lille plus
d'attraits culturels et
artistiques et plus d'activités
à offrir à nos jeunes pour
garder son intérêt pour.
- Mme Fournier vous êtes une
politicienne d'expérience vous
étiez député provincial donc il
y a un poste qui vient de
s'ouvrir...
Vous voyez Longueuil comment?
- C'est la collaboration.
On a connu quatre années
difficiles au conseil de ville
ils se les sont choisis de me
faire confiance à mon équipe et
moi c'est parce qu'on voulait
tourner la page sur ces années
est entrée dans un nouveau choc
titre.
Une heure de collaboration ou on
va s'élever au-dessus des jeux
partisanes pour améliorer le
bien-être de la population.
Juste un changement de ton dans
le développement de d'une
culture de transparence.
Un changement assez radical et
on veut rebâtir et accroître la
confiance des gens de Longueuil
envers leurs démocratiques
municipales.
- Pendant la compagne chacun de
votre côté vous êtes rejoint et
vous avez formé une alliance.
Vous trouviez qu'il faut
proposer des solutions pour la
crise du logement et le
changements climatiques.tement s
faire Mme Fournier?
- J'ai de tenir une premièree oc
Stéphane sur le sujet.
Ce que nous avions non annoncé
ce que nous allons
investigateurs d'un sommet
québécois.
Pour des solutions sur la crise
du logement autant sur le
locatif et sur la surchauffe
dans le milieu imm
On s'entend ses pas
nécessairement une municipales
et ça prend une concertation les
différents partenaires de la
société civile des paliers de
gouvernement et avec le fédéral.
C'est de réunir tout le monde
s solutions à
proprement québécoise...
On doit mettre la table des
ressources et de rassembler les
autres paliers du gouvernement à
la table.
- Il faut changer les règles
parce qu'en ce moment les règles
ne jouent pas en faveur des
jeunes et des gens qui ont de
petites économies mais qui
n'arrive plus à payer le
logement et les maisons.
Ça va prendre un bon rapport de
force avec le gouvernement là-
dedans.
C'est votre génération c'est le
moment d et
on entendait Monsieur Fernandez
disait que c'est tellement
important de faire ça marque
rapidement et de ne pas
attendre.
Jusqu'à quel point vous allait
tenter d de
force avec votre alliance ou des
actes Sud pour réussir
informellement tout de suite?
- C'est pas un enjeu qui estlita
tous intérêts à régler ce
problème-là.
On avait une inflation des prix
de 20 à 30 % dans les dernières
années donc tout le monde est
conscient de l'importance.
La collaboration est plutôt
facile e
collaboration là-dessus ce qu'on
a souhaité incarner dans leune e
qu'on est capable de travailler
ensemble.
Souvent ce que j'ai vu ça fais
huit ans que je suis conseillé
municipal souvent la menace
municipalité
c'est important de laisser cette
vieille dynamique la décennie de
tirer la couverture de son côté
et de voir comment on peut
mettre de l'avant.
Ça va de soi surtout sur la
matière de l'habitation c'est un
enjeu qui est complexe.
- Ce que vous dîtes c'est que ça
touche toute une municipalité.
Les gens disaient il reste peut-
être déçu parce que la vie est
difficile et Monsieur Fernandez
disait dans les faits dont les
grands enjeux comme les villes
n'ont pas ce pouvoir lavent sur
l'environnement et elles ont
besoin du gouvernement du Québec
et d'Ottawa et du
que vous pensez être capable de
chercher des pouvoirs ou
d'autres outils.
- Effectivement je pense que
c'est un travail où il faut
bâtir un travail de force.
Les villes doivent s'aligner
entraînent et c'est comme ça
qu'on va avoir un
important.
C'est sûr que dans le cadre d'un
de notre sommet sur l'habitation
ces sujets-là vont devoir être
traités.Les villes sont assez ls
dans leur pouvoir dans leurs
ressources donc c'est ce que
fait le fond de la pièce mais en
même temps je suis confiante qun
avancer à Longueuil avec mon
expérience comme début et j'aiux
leviers.
Ce travail de collaboration
d'aller tende la main au
gouvernement du Québec ou au
gouvernement du fédéral.
Ça ne me fait pas peur au
contraire je pense qu'il faut
l'utiliser et utiliser les
- Vous avez pas peur de grand-
chose.
Au sujet de toutes participation
très bas dans les deux cas
al M.
Boyer, il faut avoir les gens
derrière soi, vous représentez
les jeunes familles aussi et on
a l'impression qu'ils ne
viennent pas voter.
- Je crois que c'est une criseic
en général.
Le fait qu'il y avait une
élection fédérale n'a pas aidé
il y avait une certaine
lassitude sur le terrain pour
les élections de la part des
citoyens, mais cela étend dit ce
n'est pas l'ensemble des qui vol
y a une réalité particulière du
fait que beaucoup des grands
médias sont basés à Montréal et
dans les autres villes et une ba
population y vive.
Il faut des citoyens qui y
prennent goût dont ils doivent
savoir ce qui se passe.
C'est la communication.
- On va vous inviter plustous l.
Bonne chance à vous souhaite
beaucoup de courage et de force
de détermination pour passer